I'm gonna have a lightsaber that's the
weapon of an ancient religion that has
organisms that live within your body it
is a simple idea it's the kind of idea
an eight-year-old would come up with
phasers light sabers tribbles Minox look
we all enjoy a little escapism some seek
it in grandiose space operas with giant
armored monkey men while others turned a
hard-hitting sci-fi that sometimes
happens to be about whales but is one
superior to the other but it's debatable
and Team Star Trek Star Wars the
superior franchise I have been a Star
Trek fan since I was six years old I
find Star Wars the superior series Star
Trek is the best everyone knows this
Star Wars for life women in positions of
power Star Trek is a model for a more
peaceful future whereas Star Wars is
just more people shooting guns at each
other and wearing stupid outfit Star
Trek happens in the real world in the
future like a couple hundred years from
now the word Star Wars it's got the word
Wars in it so the entire premise of the
show is based on violence and fighting
where I would argue that the entirety of
Star Trek is based on a construction of
peace so everything that happens is
based on our society our technology and
how do we change how do we evolve how do
we become who we want to be that
entertainment about entertainment
that's not entertaining could also be
about intellectual stimulation
but tomato tomahto InDesign there's this
concept called symmetry it's beautiful
if you look at this does that look
symmetric to you at all look I got this
floppy DirecTV dish up here and I got
the one way you can see out the window
right here compare that to this
beautiful symmetrical ship and this is
just so symmetrical and so basic with
this you've got on solos character Star
Trek paints a world where everybody is
in one of these like everyone's in a
goddamn Prius the Millennium Falcon that
thing's [ __ ] falling apart there
reminds me of my 91 Toyota Camry what
are those for
it's aerodynamic so is this mmm this
kind of looks like a flying saucer this
is progressive you want to tell me that
this does not look like a flying saucer
you could literally put a cup of tea on
top of that thing and use it as a saucer
Star Trek is so alienating and how
perfect in and distant it is it is if
anything a pipedream of what humanity
can be and Star Wars as a reflection of
our true complex nature
I think that's [ __ ] I don't know
does Star Trek have Jar Jar Binks
what's wrong with Jar Jar Binks who
doesn't [ __ ] love charge our banks a
Star Trek it is best enjoyed after
you've graduated with a liberal arts
degree see Star Wars is a place for
imagination in the end like and and
youth to enjoy something and to get
wrapped up in a hero's tale Star Wars is
a childish tale of black versus white
good versus evil
another stupid hero trope like we need
more of that crap I guess we could delve
into the sexy fact I mean Carrie Fisher
in the bikini I mean we've got to go
with that Arnie what do you have in Star
Trek but every alien Kirk ever slept
with which is half of the aliens in the
galaxy you have William Shatner in his
prime but Han Solo I mean is there a
sexier guy than that I mean he's a man's
man you know what's the deal with the
cp3 oc3 you know his name you need a
translator for Chewbacca you need a
translator for r2d2 those aliens are so
thin they can't even speak for
themselves about a franchise that was
built for entertainment for people to
buy tickets to go to movies or watch TV
at home for them to be entertained of
course it's gonna be I'm gonna get fired
up about it if we were talking about
something like climate change sure we
can have a rational discussion and sit
here and discuss it
you could be a Luke Skywalker and have a
laser sword and be like a space samurai
that sounds like super fun I just I
can't respect people who like our Star
Wars fans over Star Trek it's nuts to me
look at how many iconic things that has
done the best villain and not to mention
like the best movie lines Luke I am your
father
everybody knows where that comes from
but that's the thing you know it's
fantasy you're in this world where where
stuff is just amazing do you want to use
the force or live long and prosper I
hope that you live long and prosper to
come to the right decision this feel
like we're never gonna see eye to eye
and nothing will ever change that
nothing will ever change that but I can
win this this I could win